joining us right now from tampa st pete
area
after watching the tampa bay lightning
take care of the montreal canadian not
five to one in uh game one of the
stanley cup
final the playoffs are coming to a head
in the world of pucks and a man who has
been covering this sport for espn
forever in a day and the voice of monday
night football and my good friend steve
levy
joining us here on the rich eisen show
how are you steve i
absolutely was going to do the saint
pete transition too
if you didn't rich you know what we're
just we're just cut from the same cloth
steve
absolutely how you doing how's it going
i'm good man everything's everything's
good we were uh
we were surprised by last night you know
you you the blowouts
uh you know you get blowouts in the nba
playoffs throughout so you don't get
that in the stanley cup play even the
best against the worst is still a one
goal game and an empty netter
so five one is is really out of
character for the sport
for the final and certainly for the
canadians so i was that was weird to see
i mean you're but you are in the uh city
of champions
steve let's be honest here city of
champions yeah they
love it uh they flash gronk on the big
scoreboard last night i think it was
taped i don't think he was actually in
the building
right uh but but it was a mad house here
anyway so imagine if bronc was here that
would have only added to the madness
so now they're fired up man uh and in
fact that's so
unfair rich you know montreal is gonna
return home
either you know one one of the series
they're down 2-0 and they're going to
have like 3 500
at the bell center and and they're going
to have 20 000 like naked people on top
of each other right outside the building
such a bizarre optic in quebec right now
no kidding
yeah that is not fair that is not fair
that is an absolute disadvantage
so um so is there a general sense that
this is the lightning
the lightnings to take right now you
know i i think uh
i think tampa bay is the better club uh
but i i think you could make the
argument that uh montreal was
was the lesser of the club in every
single round so far
right people forget you know people had
toronto sweeping them in the first round
and montreal actually went down
3-1 in that series and came back to win
then they able to sweep the more
talented winnipeg jets
and they were absolutely not supposed to
beat las vegas
and didn't even need seven then beat him
and beat him in six so you know montreal
is kind of
they got the magic right we've always
heard that expression about how the hot
goalie can
can sort of equal equal the playing
surface you know and um
and that's a big point of barry melrose
in the series montreal wherever they
have played for the last you know 12
years or whatever it is
they've always had one advantage the
same advantage going into every game
they have carry price and you don't but
that kind of stops here
because andre vasilevsky for tampa bay
you know might
might be his equal so um so that's a
really neat matchup
i thought both goals were pretty good uh
i don't blame anything like carrie price
last night but
he can't give up five goals and macho
i'll expect to win right
and so are you with melrose is he with
you steve yeah
what is uh what's it like to watch the
montreal canadien
in a stanley cup final with a guy who
had mcsorley stick checked on him
back in 93. that's that's absolutely
come up quite a few times you can
imagine actually this is a this is a
brutal series for melrose right so
uh the canadians in 93 people forget you
know barry and the kings they won game
one in montreal
they're winning game two late in
regulation they're about to go
up 2-0 and come home back to la up 2-0
in the series
and there was the uh that minor illegal
stick violation thing
and uh and of course the kings didn't
win another game so that's
that side of it and then he's here in
tampa
as you know blew his doors out after a
mere 16 games with a winning record
behind the bench i think they're still
paying him whatever but
yeah this has been a this has been a
difficult series for barry to be
involved with for sure
i love barry melrose one of my favorite
people that i got to work with and see
and but the the the the uh
canadian aspect of it too because again
we talked about this with our friend uh
the actor colin hanks yesterday a die
hard kings fan
um where they a lot of kings fans do
believe that
that the uh the canadian
and uh jacques de mer the coach at the
time
got some sort of intelligence on
mcsorley's stick that was
untoward to find out um and have
knowledge
and you know the uh the canadian haven't
been back to the
cup until now and the country of canada
hasn't won one
since then i wonder what melrose thinks
about that story is definitely been out
there rich i have also heard those
whispers and listen it was it was a
different game back then right you're
playing in those old
barns right the old martial forum like
things were just different right
security was lacks
uh there was real home ice advantage in
some of those buildings and
as you point out some of that home ice
advantage might have been in the middle
of the night right they're going into
measuring sticks
and uh and i'm sure that happened
elsewhere and the tricky part though
is to what do you do with that intel
right when it's a gamble right you know
it you know what probably before the
series starts or
you know after the first practice and so
when do you use it right at what point
in the game obviously third period
but you got to be you know trailing by a
goal like everything has to be set up at
the right time to use that
and it did work to perfection there um
barry has always taken the high road on
that budget yes
always said you know hey that's on me
i'm the head coach
those responsible to me i have heard
players say
you know they only use their illegal
sticks in the first two periods
they go to the legal curve in the third
period and that's you know some of that
responsibility is on the player
the equipment manager and those types
but uh yeah you know barry
i mean that was barry's shot you think
about it you don't get so many
opportunities you're like
you know tampa bay is ready to try to
repeat here but so many so many talented
people who played and coached
whatever don't get the opportunity to
get a sniff at the cup
and again that was barry's best chance
you imagine you would both games in
montreal
going home you have to like the king's
chances with wayne gretzky in that spot
steve levy here on the rich eisen show
when was your first sports center who'd
you do it with steve what was that
uh call ravage uh august
8th of 93 so that same year by the way
and i'll never forget mike mcquade who's
still one of my my many bosses i we have
a lot of bosses as you know rich yes
and uh he was producing the show and in
those days we did the two shot high
hello on the middle camera yep
and then whoever had the lead you'd look
down and do the traditional
tv anchor turns yes and do you know your
25 seconds 30 second lead in right so
and ravi had only been there like three
months before me the grizzled veteran
right so
he gives me this nice build up from new
york and channel 2 and the fan blah blah
we want to welcome our newest anchor
steve levy
thanks carl i say a sentence and then
you know you're supposed to look down
and turn well
i must have looked down and not turned
so i did my entire 30-second first lead
in on the two-shot on the wrong camera
yes and so ravich is trying to be you
know comforting and a good partner he's
looking at me he's looking at the camera
mcquaid is in my ear
they see camera three you know trying to
be gentle i'm definitely nervous man
it's my first show
yeah camera three camera three look left
look left you know nothing and i was
rich
there was nothing gonna get me off that
camera too that two shot
and until they rolled that video and we
were off and running but that's yeah
what was the last time you see have you
seen that footage
i mean does it exist somewhere uh i'm
sure it exists somewhere
somewhere in the basement in bristol but
i have not seen it i see the bulging
disc a lot
nobody brings out the first show is not
as popular as the bulging disc always a
good goat
you know what i speak it benefits rich
yes that's my only you know i'm not
funny as you know
no you aren't steve steve don't say that
no no that's always my go-to to try to
break the ice with a crap well and of
all the people to
have had the back problem uh and you
leave out the s
in bulging disc uh randy johnson uh of
all people
as well uh the big unit right is that
who had the bulging disc
two steve no no it was not not for me he
might still have a vulgar
who was it who had the bulging disc
maurice hearst of the patriots
uh maurice hurst junior's dad yeah he's
maury first of the new england patriots
i even tell you this story this is a
good story so yeah michigan
i'm doing a michigan game right yeah and
uh maurice hurston is playing right he's
a good player and stuff yes
on abc and i told the bruiser hey you
know we could do a blowout it could be
fun to roll in and all that stuff
so we wind up rolling it in and uh
maurice hurst jr tweets me
after the game and said something was
hey steve
i never knew that about my father
and leaves it flat there so uh yeah that
was my mortgage
oh my gosh i think that
that that was one of the stories from
real sports center
that made it into that show uh the aaron
sorkin show sports night right i think
that
did right like where but they had they
basically said that that's on the
prompter it was josh charles basically
said i'm not reading i forget what it
was but i
it made sports night that made sports
night back in the day
we did and listen this was totally on me
it was spelled correctly
in the proctor i just misspoke i was one
letter rich
one little letter i just told the story
just yesterday on yesterday's show that
my my son is at summer camp right now my
two boys were in
the same summer camp my youngest son did
the sports report on the pa system
i heard that story and and i did it in
once upon a time in my camp
too i did the sports report on the pa
but i got basically fired from the job
after doing it once
because when i was reading the box score
of the philadelphia phillies back in
1980 or 81
i left the the letter m out of mike
schmidt's last name by accident yeah
and they thought i did that on purpose
and i was one and done
so i had my hey man i know how it feels
basically but i was also in trails and
camp at the time not on sports
not sitting next to olbermann it wasn't
that's right
unfortunately for you it wasn't a read
into if i'm not mistaken it wasn't a
read into a highlight it was just a
straight sport
like a straight news read and you're
supposed to throw it to keith next
and keith was next and he had his
glasses off and wave the camera back to
you right because he was laughing
yes very close and olbermann has the
line so i say what i
said and orbit says steve do we have any
video of that
but now you know the camera starts
shaking right because everybody's
laughing
and the other the other kicker to that
story is and again you know what it's
mike mcquaid again
so he's producing that night and the
next story
this is this is amazing is uh is about
an asian figure skater
who had passed away okay so can you
imagine now we've totally lost control
of this
right right right in television terms
when you're not gonna do a story
it's it's it's kill the story let's kill
the story right
right so all right kill the asian figure
skater
you know but she's already dead and now
right here are years so
you know so we've totally lost it now
and so i'm going through a rip
of uh of nfl like season ending career
ending
injuries and trying not to lose you know
to lose it
and keith absolutely is crying and uh
and the only reason i was there is
because dan took the night off dan had
i don't know his daughter was graduating
or something like that i was filling in
for dan
it was coming out of monday night
football like it was the worst possible
spot
and uh i really thought i was gonna get
fired the next day
steve we got a screen grabbing you from
that this hearst with the over the
shoulder of maurice hurst senior right
there night
that you don't have that tie anymore
that's for sure i don't think you have
that
anymore look at you
it's got a hell of a pattern oh my gosh
that's oh my yeah that's uh
how about how about me myself was i too
thin okay
steve you look great i'm not gonna lie
oh you look great hair is tremendous
i mean seriously that is a head of
lettuce i had one too but
you know oh well look have a great uh
time with the uh with the cop
um uh let's let's do this again uh in
the summer as you're getting ready to
call monday night football we'll talk
some
we'll talk some ball with you i'd love
it absolutely that'd be great thanks for
having me thanks donald
absolutely so you're on tonight right
you're doing a sportscenter hit you're
doing all that sportscenter stuff yep
exactly i'll see you then steve thanks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here